you always knew that some people liked
them and some people didn't and that's
kind of quite varied in so much as you
know the majority of places that we went
people were always very welcoming and
glad to see them um but you know there
was always somebody who may be an
anti-monachist at one level all the way
through to somebody who was maybe a
fixated individual who wanted to do that
member of the royal family ha
[Music]
thank you
in kind of like layman's terms could you
explain what the role of Royal
protection is royalty protection their
their Pacific department and in my time
it was called so14 royalty protection
especially stops 14. and their role was
to look after members of their royal
family and that department was split
into three sections there was the the
uniformed officers who are responsible
for the the physical security of the
royal palaces there was the protection
officers who were responsible for the
personal security of members of those
royal families so ultimately the
bodyguards and members of the special
escort group formed the third strand of
the department they are the motorcycle
outriders that escort
um not just the royal family government
ministers they also have responsibility
for high value loads category a
prisoners back and forth Court they they
have an escort role and they're all part
of of role protection
how many world protection officers are
working for the royal family and is it a
case that there's one assigned to each
Royal at any given time or is there
multiple depending on the day
yeah I mean the the model
um within royalty protection of how many
officers deployed constantly changes
um yes there are team members who are
set aside to permanently work with that
particular member of the family and then
other members like myself support
those teams with regards to numbers
there's always a there's always a
minimum of one and then after that we
build it up accordingly now that is a is
a foundation of threat and risk that
could be in relation to international
events it could be in relation to a
local event it could be based purely on
the geography of where you're going and
how many protection officers you feel
you need to have a successful day so
it's constantly a sliding process as to
how many you get but when I was in
royalty protection we had
107 protection officers across the board
which when you compare that to the
secret service at that time which is
about four and a half thousand strong
um you know things done in a slightly
slightly different way
and it probably changes day to day but
could you give an insight into what a
day in the life of a royalty Protection
Officer might might look like
yeah I mean a day in the life of a
Protection Officer
varied if you were to follow a
Protection Officer around for for a
month you must probably find it
extremely boring because you spend a lot
of time
in meetings you spend a lot of time on
the planning table going through the
what ifs the last 12 months you know
we've seen three large State occasions
from the Queen's Platinum Jubilee
through to the The Queen's funeral and
then the king's coronation you know none
of that was just thrown together you
know as as people talk about operation
London Bridge operation London Bridge
has been in place since the 1960s
constantly being evaluated constantly
evolving it's the similar mentality when
you're planning
um a royal visit whether that be an
occasion whereby we're going to open or
close something or indeed on a much
smaller scale but still the same level
of planning if this is a a private visit
a protection officer's day
is actually months worth of planning to
get to that to get to that point but
sometimes as a Protection Officer
certainly working with younger members
they're all family that's when you get
to push your skills almost probably to
the boundaries because a lot of that
planning a lot of that planning will go
out the window it's just not possible
you know we could be looking at a
weekend in London and certainly when
Prince William and Harry were were
younger and in their informative years
you know very similar to lots of other
people of that age you know we would say
you know what's happening this weekend
don't know yet okay any idea no waiting
on a phone call which you know on a
Friday and Saturday evening a lot of
other younger people are also in exactly
the same position oh we we may be going
to the cinema we may be going to this
restaurant we may be going to this Pub
for a drink and maybe go into my
friend's house and then you get the
phone call no I'm going out
okay where are you going don't know yet
but we need to Head West Chelsea Fulham
yeah yeah let's go you know and you're
you're wandering out not 100 knowing
what you're doing which you know really
puts up the or rather you know what
you're doing as a Protection Team you
just don't know where you're going to
um you worked closely with the late
Queen what was she like
yeah I mean the queen was great to work
with
um in around
the Queen's team everything the queen
did pretty much run on Rails you know
there was a big mechanism around the
queen to support those those visits and
I can remember as a as a child the queen
came to Swansea to open the Leisure
Center which is I think right about 1977
1978 and then many years later the queen
went back to open the new Swansea
Leisure Center and I was part of that
Protection Team to actually take the
queen
just to open that legend that I'd seen
her open nearly 30 years before that
things like that are great you know
that's what you that's what you remember
as a Protection Officer you know and you
do see sides to all members of the royal
family that you know aren't necessarily
out in the public domain you know for
argument's sake when
um the Prince of Wales he was then the
king you know used to go to
um the military Hospital in in
Birmingham to see the returning soldiers
who would you know in some cases had uh
life-changing life shortening injuries
because of what we'd asked them to do in
in the in the war on terror and the the
king would spend all day there you know
there was never any rush to to leave and
he would talk to everybody you know
these young servicemen coming back you
know who had lost lost limbs you know
very much a people person which from a
protection perspective brings its
challenges because you know he does want
to go and speak to people you know
thankfully in my day the modern
phenomena of the selfie didn't really
exist but you know now that is part and
parcel of any Royal Engagement is is the
selfie you know and you're putting you
know a senior member of their old family
really close to someone you know and
also they don't want you in that picture
either so you know you've got to be in a
position whereby you can react but you
know simply not spoil somebody's kind of
once in a lifetime moment as well so you
always knew that some people like them
and some people didn't
um and that's kind of quite varied in so
much as you know the majority of places
that we went people were always very
welcoming and glad to see them um but
you know there was always somebody who
may be an anti-monachist at one level
all the way through to somebody who was
maybe a fixated individual who wanted to
do that member of the royal family ha
somebody who wishes to cause you
embarrassment or cause you harm only has
to ever get it right once and certainly
in the in the global 24-hour media that
we now live in that is that information
that incident happens immediately and is
out there forever and a day and that has
massive
consequences
um because everything that
the UK stands for to a certain extent is
is on display
and in your opinion what is the greatest
threat to the royal family I think the
greatest threat is is most probably
difficult to kind of pinpoint because
they're all threats but they all have
different
connotations attached to them you know
the greatest threat ultimately is
somebody who wishes to take their life
if you look at the threat with regards
to
um the single cause issue people who
wish to use the world's media for an
event to highlight their events such as
the anti-monarchist movement or indeed
just stop oil with regards to
actions of a demonstrator they could be
very similar to the actions of a
terrorist carrying an IED in a rucksack
you know they jump across the barriers
and they start to run towards the Royal
carriage
okay they're only going to unfold a
banner but at that pivotal moment you
don't know what they're going to do and
you know the pressure on
police officers to get that decision
right to arm police officers to get that
decision right
could have severe consequences so yeah
it is a constantly changing
threat environment you know and as the
Protection Officer and as policing as a
whole You've got to make sure that you
are
up to that response
I want to ask about the relationship
between the Royals and the paparazzi
especially after what happened to Diana
what were the paparazzi like and what
were your interactions like with them I
mean you know there's the there's the
press and there's the the paparazzi and
you know the Press are confined by a
series of
um
conventions that they've that they've
signed up to so you know to a certain
extent the regulated press aren't your
aren't your issue
they very much know what they can and
can't do but with regards to Paparazzi
you know they don't they don't
play by the same rules it was always
difficult because
I fully understand you know how
much value there is from a Paparazzi
perspective to some of these photos that
are taken you know the the sheer money
that is involved and and kind of many
years ago
and being with the Duke of Sussex and
seeing the same guy take the same
picture almost every week as we were
coming out of a certain restaurant you
know I said look why you why are you
taking the same picture you know you
must have hundreds of pictures of us you
know I doubt it's a I doubt it's a
fashion thing to critique the the Duke's
clothing on this particular night you
know why why are you taking the same
photo over and over again
um and the gentleman just simply replied
back to me this may be the last picture
of him alive
and that to me is worth a lot of money
did you ever feel like any members of
the royal family were frustrated with
constantly having to be protected and
accompanied everywhere they weren't no I
don't think so I think it's most
probably because they're all family get
cradle degree of protection it's kind of
what they know most probably the only
different scenario is that those people
that marry into the royal family
um you know that is most probably a a
bit of an adjustment but then you work
as a team you work all around that to
make sure that they are comfortable with
what they're getting
um you you kind of fully understand why
you're there
you you get that these people your
principals want to have a as much of a
normal life as possible and you you have
to facilitate that
um you know the easiest thing in the
world is just to say we'll stay in
don't go out you know we've got big
fences we've got kind of policemen with
guns on the outside you know
everything's fine and we'll bring
everything to you
that's not
realistic senior members of the family
still want to kind of function they
still want to go and see you know other
friends other family members they still
want to go and do things outside of the
official kind of capacity
with regards to Harry and Megan
obviously they step back as serving
Royals did you ever see that coming from
Harry
um
in all our honesty now but then you know
the latter part of
um the years the the involvement
um and his relationship emerged to
um The Duchess of Sussex I wasn't
involved in that so you know I kind of
knew him when he was a
um a young prince you know and and no I
kind of couldn't couldn't see that you
know I thought he was very very
committed to the family very extremely
committed to his military career they're
the only ones that can evaluate that
decision to kind of step away from the
royal family I mean I think if you look
at the purely my side of things the
protection side of things then you know
they've stepped away from that away from
having royalty protection that's
certainly from the Duke's perspective
you know he's had since he was born you
know it's an extremely emotive issue
um on all on all sides you're not just
that of the sussexes you know it's an
emotive issue of the Police Service who
are ultimately the deliverers of that
that protection and from the
the taxpayers side of things you know
who's going to pay for it but then the
flip side of that is
you know you are talking about the
King's son you know I talk about the
future King's brother
um he is a military veteran having
served two tours of Afghanistan there is
a duty of care issue attached to that as
well based on threat and risk but you
know there are other members they're all
family who
um no longer have police protection and
indeed have private protection so you
know it's not it's not the first time
but certainly you know it was their
decision and they're the only ones that
can evaluate whether that was a positive
or negative move do you think they're a
close family
um again you know from
my experience yes as a family their
their family life is is under the
microscope it's you know drawn out in
the public kind of gaze you know there's
always interaction you know when you
look at you know summer Court in
Balmoral Christmas Court in Sandringham
you know all the family kind of are
there you know they all interact kind of
with each other but you know as with all
families you know they have their kind
of disagreements and they have their
um time that they want to maybe spend
away from each other
in the event of a hypothetical attack
as a Protection Officer are you expected
to put your life in front of the Royals
um yes there is the Hollywood view of
you know kind of standing in the way
taking the bullet but you know really
you should
see lots of these things before they
kind of happen that's that's why you've
been trained to that level that's why
you're there okay I'm not naive enough
to say that you're gonna you know stop
it every single time because something
could take your attention away and you
could have could miss that but
ultimately I suppose there is a
consideration that that's what you may
have to do to provide kind of effective
Body cover I mean if you're looking at
you know were there ever that kind of
life-threatening moment then no I never
had one
um you know far more uh
more life-threatening moments on the
Firearms team and on the on the tsg so
you know I never had you know some of
the the critical instance that we've had
you know as Roger's protection as a
department you know with the Princess
Royal being attempt to kidnap on the Mao
um Marcus Sergeant shooting at the queen
tripping the color the the Prince of
Wales as he was there in Australia I
never had any of those moments you know
thankfully
um you know you have
long date you know and sometimes you
know those long days you know certainly
when you're doing things like Wales week
or Scotland week you know it just it's
constant you know and you're rolling
into it
um you know your Royal walk about is
your critical time you know and the
first time I ever did that was down in
Brighton
um with the late queen and the late Duke
of Edinburgh and they went down there
um for the day and I got back in the car
having only done a 15-minute walkabout
and I was just physically mentally
drained the Protection Officer I was
with just looked at me you know and said
it'll get better as time goes on but you
know fortunately for me I never had a
critical situation but a lot of that is
because of the planning that goes into
your event and the support that you get
given
um by other stakeholders and and other
police officers as well for your event
how long in total did you work as a
royal Protection Officer and why did you
make the decision to leave so I was a
Protection Officer from 2007 2013 and
then
um I made a decision to leave
Metropolitan Police Service and have a
look at what the the private sector
would be like for someone with my skill
set you know and that's when I set up
Trojan consultancy and now we're a team
of former police officers I'm very
fortunate that everybody on the team are
people that I worked with trained or
both
so that's really good I know everybody's
skill set but I also know everybody's
personality as well
um it's it's different you know whilst
the work is is the same okay there's
some things you haven't got we haven't
got the the badges and the guns anymore
but you know we've got the vast
experience you get to meet some nice
people you get to work for some nice
people you get to go into nice
environments okay you can't get
completely absorbed by it you can't get
red carpet fever as we used to call it
and you know think that actually the
principal's life is your life you know
you're there to support them in exactly
the same way as the
um as the PA as the chef as the gardener
so you firmly got to have an
understanding of your position and again
I think you know with Trojan consultancy
we we have that understanding because
we've we've spent so many years working
with senior members of royal family
um Prime Ministers senior government
minister there's people coming into the
UK who require kind of protection and
whilst you might be going to the theater
this evening and then going to a
five-star Michelin restaurant and then
you'd you know drive home in the Bentley
and put your principal back into their
30 million pound house you know you then
go home and finish because you've handed
over to to another team to take on the
rest of it you know you're back at the
school gate tomorrow morning dropping
your your children off talking to the
other dads and you know the next meal
you have is a Nando's
on this particular occasion went into
Prince Andrew's bedroom and his
apartments and on his bed was 72 teddy
bears on his bed the mice have to put
them back exactly like it's in that
picture they said if they don't it
shouts and screams